hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and this is a follow-up video from the
video i did earlier this week on bitcoin
and i'm using a 15 minute chart
in bitcoin now the data feed comes from
coinbase you know a few
traders have asked me where am i getting
my data feed right if you download
ninjatrader
if you're using ninjatrader
you can
go to connections and you could connect
to coinbase right in here for free it's
very simple to set up all you really got
to do is you just find it under
connections
it's just right in here you just would
you would just click on it and add it i
already got it added but you don't have
to enter any
username or password
all right so
that out of the way uh last time
i left you
it was on the 30th which was what day
was that i think wednesday um bitcoin
was coming down into this 47 100 area
47.50
you know and we had this
zone being drawn out here this little
green box if you can see it on on the
video um you know this was an area i was
looking for support to come in and
actually came right into that area and
it got a little bit past it i mean it
traded all the way down to like around
uh
you know the 865-ish area down in here
and actually put in another
support area so we had one support area
where the market came into and it still
showed more support there market rallied
up a little bit and came right down into
that support area around you know the 46
950 46
900 area okay so it it held
for the most part here started rallying
back up okay we went all the way up to
um
what was it here 47
i need my glasses here
47 700. and what was interesting about
this and really this is what makes
using order flow
so interesting and so useful is seeing
the actual
amount of bitcoin that trades at price
levels and
what is traded on the bid what's traded
on the offer you know if you're just
looking at normal candlestick charts
you're not taking into account the
amount of bitcoin that was trading
because you know we got this nice little
rally going
and it just sort of ran out of steam up
here
and started selling off
and if you're looking at the order flow
you could see that there were big
sellers coming in right after we got up
to around the 700 level right you this
is a 15-minute chart again so you know
this is a 15-minute bar it's a 15-minute
bar
15-minute bar so you had been trading up
around you know the 46
sorry 47
um
you know 650 47 700 area and now we're
starting to see some sellers come in
here working offers
right coming in you can see this
imbalance of 22 12 6. markets start
selling off another 18 another 12
another 11.
you know this right here i mean if if
you're not using a footprint chart at
all on bitcoin you know you're really
leaving a lot of information on the
table now you know i create these videos
these are more meant for traders not for
you know hodlers or diamond hand people
you know this is meant for people that
are active traders
not you know not just buy and hold and
buy and forget type traders these are
people that are actively uh trading in
the market so once you start seeing
these sellers come in right this is an
area we've got we're going sideways for
45 minutes and then the sellers came in
here with supply which weighs on the
market and what happens to the market
you know market sells off naturally
right it sells all the way down to
around you know the 4700 so you know it
was a pretty
quick drop of about uh 500 bucks
and then we just start going sideways
right you've got a support area drawn in
here
you can just see how the mark is just
going sideways uh for the next
you know what is that it's almost half a
day coming into um
the 31st and on the 31st again we start
making that move back all the way up to
700 again 47 700 but as you get up there
right you got more supply coming in 47
uh just below 47 600 you can see there's
77 bitcoin that traded on the offer
right earlier right what was that area
that we traded up to where you had the
sellers coming in here right we got the
22 the 12 to 6 even down here is 18 but
you know you got that supply coming in
again around the 47
uh you know we'll call it 47
660 area now you sell off you come back
up to that area just a little bit lower
now it's at 47
575 so you're sort of coming back into
an area where you ran into supply
earlier right you ran into supply here
now you're making another run up towards
that supply
area but you run into more supply there
okay
and you can see the big candle down just
reverses quite dramatically right
there's that's a lot of bitcoin to be
you know for people to be selling at a
level you know people always wonder you
know why why does the market
come off from a level well it comes off
after rallies when there's supply in the
market
and the market starts dropping down but
it sort of coming down into this 47
you know 130 area of 47 100 and there is
support here right 47 100 you can see
the 25 traded here 62 traded here
bitcoin um just
a little bit above you know around the
47 130 areas 21 so you're running into
some supportive bids on the way down
and the market's just getting right
through them
okay which is
again significant because normally you'd
expect um you know
this is what 262 sorry 25 plus 62 what
is that 87 bitcoin right and it trades
through that and even goes offered there
there's a decent offer trades 18 when
it's offered out there so it's about 100
bitcoin someone came in and sold and
even turned it offered and then just
below that there's some decent bids 25
34 35 35 31 18.
right that's um what is this that's you
know plus the 10 here you know you're
looking at
nearly a hundred and you know i don't
know 175 just roughly here um between
60 47 060 and you know 4700 so there's
decent support literally from 47
100 down to 47 000
which
right if you're looking at
you know the amount of bitcoin that's
there that's a couple hundred bitcoin
between these two levels you would
expect that to support the market
but it doesn't right it just gets right
through it and as we're in the next bar
you can see some decent offers coming
here 22
38 40 28.
this is an important part you know i
just want you to remember this
when you have big bids
in the market right that should act as a
port
but when it doesn't as market starts
trading through and then around that
level or just on the other side of it
you see heavy offers come in
you know that the market's got a head of
steam because you have the big bids
there to support the market but somebody
traded through it
and not only did they trade through it
but they're still got more to sell as
evidenced by what's up trading on the
offer right because they're just not
going to come through they're going to
see these big bids hit them they're
happy to hit those because that size
that they could get done without moving
but then they're still going to be
working offers offers offers offers
because they just want to hit everything
in the order book right because then the
market will drop further you know
obviously they want to
keep the market at a low level so they
could attract some buyers coming in you
know people saying oh you know there's
support there because you know that's
what traders like to do right they like
to buy support so if they're looking at
this 47 100 as an area of support
but the big seller
who's got a lot of supply to sell
realizes that he's just going to offer
it out because now traders you know
that's what they're taught you buy at
support you sell that resistance well
this other trader you know he's got
something else in mind because he's got
more supply than these buyers that are
coming in
can afford to buy
so he's just happy to absorb all their
buying coming in here thinking that
we're at support when the support fails
and the market drops further right it
drops from you know the 4700 area
you know literally in two bars it drops
all the way down to
uh you know 46
you know 220
area just sort of goes sideways and
falls over again some more there was
some support trying to come in here to
prop up this market around the 46 660
area to you know 46 620 630
i'm sorry 46 600 to
you know 620
but it couldn't hold the market up and
market proceeded to keep dropping
and you know it worked its way down it
got down to
um you know the 45 600 ish area down in
here on this bar
but you know more or less it just kept
dropping and got down here
now
what was interesting is
on this bar here this was um on the 31st
on was that thursday
there was 71 contracts or 71 bitcoin
rather
offered out down here
okay which
you know you would sort of expect that
to
help propel the market lower but the
market got through that and what was
interesting is you know when you
you just had a drop okay
from 47 right up here 47 600
all the way down
you know to
almost 45 600 this was like 45 700.
so that was a significant move some of
this probably could just be
you know um well i'll say margin calls
but you know
positions getting blown out or you know
maybe stops or who knows what but when i
see some a big size like that coming in
at a low and it doesn't help propel the
market lower um
you know i'm more inclined to think that
that's not
new selling right because a big seller
you know like uh
i don't know what you're gonna call a
whale or something like that isn't gonna
sell after you just dropped about two
thousand dollars right he's he's the one
that's gonna be up near the high selling
up near the high causing the market to
sell off these people that are selling
down here um you know or are trapped
from higher levels where
they bought higher and now they want to
get out
but from this level the market just more
or less went sideways you know on
thursday and into thursday evening
started dropping down
a bit more
excuse me
nothing major really happening here in
these in these bars in the order flow
now when it gets down to this 45 100 now
again this was an interesting level
45 100 there's 110 on the bid here
and it just traded right through it no
problem in in that bar
and
again this sort of goes back to levels
that can't hold right like i was showing
you earlier you had those
levels where there was like 60 bitcoin
38 36 35 bitcoin when you add them all
up it was significant here it's all
coming in at one level so there was
again support in the market and see this
green area from earlier right this is a
support area so i'm not surprised to see
the support
in here in the order flow
so it's kind of you know expecting this
to more or less hold and then the next
bar opens up and it can't even start to
move higher okay can't even get past the
high of the previous bar and then again
it just trades right through this 45 100
area
right and it dropped pretty quick down
to 44 300.
so when you have
again you have support in the market
that isn't supporting the market and by
support i mean
bids in the market actual bids in the
order book the real liquidity
that the market just trades right
whoops
sorry about that uh where the market
just trades right through that liquidity
it keeps it's just going to keep selling
off right so we drop
almost um you know that was a thousand
dollars but about 700 from 45 100 down
to about you know 44 300
pretty quick over the next and it's just
a straight down move one two three four
five bars that's on a 15 chart you know
that's just over an hour
and then
again it started to rally up
but it's it's sort of this half-hearted
rally um volume isn't anything
spectacular nothing spectacular in the
order flow but we did manage to rally
from you know that 44 300 back up to
more or less 40
what is that 40
for
300 so
i'm sorry 45 300 get my handles right
and
then
what was interesting as you're coming up
in here
there was
you know the delta started getting kind
of small okay you can see in here
you know you just had this nice rally
up
but then you sort of get up here and you
just got these small deltas of three of
0.7 so not even one bitcoin
is the delta right the delta is the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers and
there's a couple meanings
of what can happen next or what you
should expect to happen next
um you know when you start seeing deltas
getting small well it's telling you that
the aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers are evenly matched however in
this case
the volume here is kind of light it's
only 81 bitcoin
the previous bar had 137
that had a
delta of three so you sort of coming up
here to this high and you just sort of
get this feeling that you know this move
is pretty much over right because
even though it's positive delta
it's it's not strong anymore it's just
it's really kind of weak to neutral in
the sense that
aggressive buyers
aren't
really in control that much even though
it's positive three and you know 0.7
it's not much you'd want to see
legitimate numbers you know 23 21 19 and
it just gets small and that's a sign you
know i was kind of looking for this
market to probably sell off a little bit
but in this case it just went sideways
then you know it moved down to
44 750 ish area so not a big move about
you know 250 bucks
more or less because you know you're
looking in here around the 45 100
and it just comes down to you know 44
800.
then it started rallying and
on this rally
you start seeing some interesting things
in the order flow right you start seeing
the order flow sequencing coming in here
where bigger offers are being taken out
okay and
um
again in here and i talked about this in
my
course on
uh crypto
about the min delta numbers you know
it's very strong positive delta that
you're seeing in here and usually when
you see deltas like this this it's
usually it's a market that's got a head
of steam and you can see how the market
just put in this nice rally and
more importantly you're seeing not only
are you seeing decent sized bids being
taken out
a certain decent size offers being taken
out you're seeing decent sized bids come
in as well
right you're seeing the sequencing
coming in here you know so you see the
the offers being taken out
and as you start popping up right you
get above this area look at this 45
and you start seeing nice supportive
bids coming in 16 13 13
10 even here 15 11 14 12 18 14 11. so
you're seeing that supportive bidding
coming in so not only are you lifting
the offers but you're also seeing
supportive bids come in then you get up
here to this new swing high and at that
swing high of 45 600 you know there's 37
bitcoin being
worked on the bid um 18 30
that are being traded right so
um yeah plus another 10 there so you're
looking at
you know close to 100 bitcoin
being bid right here and
it's absorbing whatever selling is
coming into the market right because
remember we're just we're sort of
popping out to new swing highs here and
as you're popping out you're seeing the
supportive buying coming in you're
seeing
traders
working bids up here
you know people are selling to them but
they're absorbing it all and when you
see absorption on a move higher chances
are the market's going to move higher
and it did it got up to
you know what is this
almost 47 800
okay so now this is on on friday
friday morning this is about 10 10 30 in
the morning
and
it starts going sideways up in here but
again watch what's happening in the
delta right you got this big bar big
positive delta of 171. a lot of bitcoin
traded 600 bitcoin in this bar 661
and then the next bar trades 325 bitcoin
which is nice
but the delta
is what the delta is only
four
that's nothing
all right it's kind of neutral so now
traders are pretty much
i mean we don't call it um you know
traders are
pretty much even
okay so now it's found in a level once
you start seeing that you're looking for
maybe a market to find
its values you know its balance area
and it does it just goes sideways more
or less for the next hour
and again spends the next rest of the
afternoon basically trading between
what is that 650
you know and down here 40
you know we'll call it 46 000
and it's just trading sideways does pop
up
in the evening time gets all the way
back up here but again you're running
into more size up in here
right now this is a friday night
and then again you start going inside
right small deltas right you got the big
bar with big positive delta and then a
bar with very small delta right what's
that mean oftentimes it means the mark
is just going to go sideways
and it does
um
hang on a second
[Music]
sorry about that so as we come into you
know this is a saturday morning now on
april the 2nd right at 7 20. we had this
some volatility come in here we had this
bar right it traded all the way down to
about the 46
250 area
and
you know this is
let me just sort of scrunch this up a
little bit here
um
you know there's a saying
in the markets right if it prints there
right because this low of 46 250 um you
know it hasn't been hit there since the
night before and
you know sometimes you know people get
excited they see this market starts
selling off they start selling and they
realize they're wrong
and then they start covering it right
where they cover they cover up here
okay
and
there's a saying right if it prints
there it can trade there so i'm kind of
looking for this market to come back to
this area this 46 250 right because this
is an area that it just sort of spiked
down there and anytime i see a spike in
the market like that
i'm always looking for potentially the
market to come back to that area and so
this market you know it spiked down here
to this 46 250 area came back up then
started drifting down where 46 250.
now that's i'm not going to say that
yeah well you know as soon as it comes
up here i'm going to sell but i do know
i have resistance overhead here
right right up in here i have some
resistance
and it's ran into that area and it's
kind of holding and as it starts coming
off you know i want to look
is this selling is there anything
interesting in the selling that you know
would want to make me get short for a
play down into this area of around 46
250 down in here
and i start to see some offers come in
but more importantly i'm starting to see
some bids come in here i see this 21.
now
what do i have okay so this is an area
that we had just been trading at you
know about a half hour earlier okay so
it's not like a new low or anything it's
an area that we came in so i see
somebody um you know i see traders
bidding this market for you know over 20
bitcoin
but more importantly what do i see next
happen i see a trade out and i see it go
offered here right there's 23 trade on
the offer so you know that's a flip
of about you know from
strong bidding to strong
selling
right but in this case it's strong
passive bidding to strong passive
selling meaning that there's supply here
now obviously it did trade out and the
market drifted a little bit higher and
then came back down
to that level and it started to stay
below there okay so then again what i'm
gonna be looking for now again we had
just been trading in this area so i'm
looking for potential support in this
market to potentially
stop this move down because
remember what i just said if it if it
prints there it can trade there so
you know i'm looking for
reasons to get short and i start seeing
some you know these are not strong bids
by any mean five and six bitcoin um when
i see some offers decent offers 10 okay
then i see another 10 on the bid here
and trades through that okay maybe at
this point you know from 650 you know
that's a
that's that's a slam dunk trade it's a
easy 250
250 move you know i mean people aren't
going to think well you know bitcoins 46
000. what's 250 but that's a nice
move right there that's
doesn't have any resistance on the way
down and then it just hits that area
goes sideways does come off a little bit
later right now i'm shooting this video
it's about three in the afternoon we had
this big bar down
where it dropped from
basically around the 46
400 area
down into the 45
700 area
now there wasn't any big volume you know
on the way down about the biggest level
i think was this nine bitcoin or you
know here's 11 12 16. okay so i ran into
some support here
um
you know and it did trade lower but then
sort of snap back and again just going
sideways down on this big bar down with
the big delta of minus 95 the next bar
is the inside bar again you usually you
know you can get a big bar down
oftentimes you're gonna get an next bar
is gonna be an inside bar
it's got decent delta 31 or sorry 23.
you can see it right here
and then the next bar inside it's just
mark it's now consolidating right now
we'll see what's going to happen you
know it did run into support resistance
up here
around the 46 300 area
but again
it's
probably going to get through that i
think it's quite going to start to rally
there's nothing in here really that's
telling me this market is looking to
sell off some more but you know i could
be the reverse market indicator but
again there's it's saturday afternoon
there's not a whole lot of size going
going on in here you see in some of
these bars kind of small volumes 58
bitcoin um 47 bitcoin 54 bitcoin
now
um again you know if you're new to order
flow really all you're looking for is
where the big volumes are i mean that
that's
it in his basic sense you know in the
old days when you know these guys are
standing around the ticker tape watching
the numbers come out really they're just
looking for the
certain things in the order flow and you
know i'm just making these videos to
sort of enlighten you on you know if in
the future you do decide to become a
more active trader than um you know a
hodler or diamond hands um you know
order flow is a great tool because it's
going to allow you to see inside
of the bar basically by by recognizing
what trades on the bid what trades on
the offer
so if you like this video be sure to
subscribe to my channel
hit the like button below and i'll see
you guys on the inside